le clos lucé à amboise fête ses 50 ans
d'ouverture au public pour l'occasion la
demeure de léonard de vinci s'orne d'une
16e machine dessiné par l'ancien maître
des lieux 12 pentagone symbolisant la
proportion divine natel le maire karine
dubois
un polyèdre rassemblant 12 pentagone
donne en géométrie un dodécaèdre cette
forme parfaite léonard de vinci l'a
imaginé en 1496 dans cette géométrie
inspiré du nombre d'or le lointain
locataires du clos lucé nous rappelle
qu'à la renaissance la science
mathématique côtoyé le divin le
dodécaèdre est un solide parfait qui
intègrent ces magnifiques dimension
mathématiques ses proportions telles
qu'elles ne sont pas reproductibles
autrement c'est la seizième machine
dessiné par léonard de vinci qui est
installée au clos lucé les deux mille
visiteurs de la journée portes ouvertes
ont pu la découvrir aujourd'hui il vit à
maintenant 50 ans que la famille saint
bris se bat pour ouvrir ce lieu au
public initié par le père ce combat a
été repris par son fils jean saint bris
son décès brutal en mars dernier
n'entament pas la volonté familiale
c'est un de ses frères qui reprend le
flambeau c'est un contexte toujours
difficile mais nous sommes tous
regroupés après le décès de notre frère
en famille pour poursuivre leur
familiale
c'est l'histoire de la madeleine de
proust et les soirs de l'enfance nous
avons passé notre enfance ici à jouer
dans ce parc a joué au jeu de françois
1er parce que françois 1er jeune enfant
était ici et bien nous sommes pris par
part par la magie de léonard et ici il y
avait véritablement quelque chose qui
qui vous prend et ne vous lâche plus
pour que les amboisiens deviennent eux
aussi les ambassadeurs du clos lucé une
nouvelle carte leur offre l'accès
illimité toute l'année pour le prix
d'une entrée